la furia sostenida en las calles es
decir la ncaa acabó con la dinastía
política rajapaksa que durante casi dos
décadas dominó la escena institucional
del país fue marginada rajapaksa hermano
del actual mandatario saliente j bay a
raya pax a quien cimentó el ascenso del
clan primero como primer ministro y
luego como presidente en dos mandatos de
2005 a 2015 durante ese tiempo jota
valla ocupó el cargo de ministro de
defensa siendo el ideólogo de la brutal
campaña que puso fin a tres décadas de
insurgencia de los tigres tamiles por lo
que fue nombrado como héroe de guerra
pero también acusado de violaciones de
derechos humanos con un breve receso del
poder tras perder las elecciones de 2015
votaba ya se impuso como presidente en
2019 respaldado por los nacionalistas
budistas cingaleses el mayor grupo
étnico en sir lanka una vez recuperado
el cargo el mandatario puso a su hermano
y ex presidente como primer ministro y
entregó otros puestos en su gobierno a
varios miembros de su familia entre
ellos nombró a su hermano basil
rajapaksa como ministro de finanzas
mientras la economía de la nación se iba
a pique así como su legado político
después del asalto a la casa del
presidente por parte de la gente que las
fuerzas militares y de seguridad no
pudieron detener porque había mucha
gente detrás quedó claro que hay un
consenso en el país de que la dirección
del gobierno debe cambiar de años de
agitación e inestabilidad social y un
gran endeudamiento culminaron con la
abrupta salida del país del mandatario
de 73 años las icónicas imágenes de
miles de manifestantes asaltando las
instalaciones gubernamentales al grito
de vete a casa j